as a scientists do you see any
relationship between religion and
science what is your stand on the exists
Supreme Being well I'm quite heavily
involved in this question as some of you
might know and I take a stand quite a
rigid stand on it people like Richard
Dawkins and sam Harris Daniel Dennett
and others who are well known for
speaking out about the science friends
of mine I'll say I said it before but
I'll say it again to this question
science is an arid term it really is it
doesn't it's not understood some people
think it's you know science is just all
this technology around it but no it's
something much deeper than that science
and scientific thinking scientific
method is for me the only philosophic
construct that the human race has
developed to determine what it is
reliably true and what can be true and
what is patently cannot be true and it
depends on evidence it dint depends on
questioning and doubting now religion
depends on just the opposite it repent
depends on no doubt and it depends on
belief and in fact Abelar said famous
religious philosopher by doubting we
come to question and by questioning we
arrive at truth
now as everything that we do in science
depends on evidence what does it mean it
means well for instance I have a four
out of five rule which is if you have a
theory and by that you might some people
say a hypothesis that about something
then you make an observation
we'll really think of three or four or
five other questions that need to be
answered if you to ensure that your
hypothesis is correct if four out of
five of your experiments work then
you're almost and I say almost certainly
right if only one out of five fit your
almost and I stress almost certainly
wrong and that was the case for c60
basically we did several experiments
after we conjectured that it was a
soccer ball and four out of five or was
five out of five all fitted for instance
seventy had to be the second magic
number which it was you could put
something on the inside so it's a cage
and Rick and Bob found that as you made
the case smaller you could put oh yeah
you could only put smaller smaller atoms
there were lots of little pointers to
indicate that that we were correct and
we were fundamentally proven to be sold
in 1990 by Karen Huffman now I believe
when I say there is a conflict between
science and religion there are some
scientists who say that's not the case
there's no company well there is there
may not be a conflict in their mind but
there definitely is a conflict in mine
because it's an ethical issue is how do
i how do I convince you that's c60 that
this thing we have a sixty carbonate and
well the mass is 720 that's the evidence
now you go to Arena how can I convince
you that religious right and what's the
evidence well there's no evidence
whatsoever and Rossmore which God are we
talking about he talking to the god of
the Hindus or the gods of the Shinto in
Japan or the God of the Supreme Being of
the seminoles or the the rain serpent or
the Great Spirit of the
Aborigines of Australia all the gods of
the Aztecs all the numerous other
mystical graves of the Greeks and I
don't think there's any evidence for
this that doesn't mean that religion
isn't important it's important to a lot
of people but I'm not going to discuss
that there is a conflict in my mind
because I need evidence for truth and if
you need evidence for truth religion
doesn't have any it just has belief now
you could say I say I'm an atheist then
some people said well you can't be an
atheist you recite you have to be an
agnostic well okay but what are you
agnostic about I mean you know okay I so
I say okay I'm an agnostic and what does
that mean it means that you can't prove
you can't there's no proof there isn't a
god well all right fair enough but what
do you mean by God what is this concept
of the God that you're talking about and
I can't think I don't I've no no one's
ever come up to me and give me a concept
of a god to be agnostic about so if you
say you're agnostic what are you
agnostic about and then the whole thing
falls into things that don't make sense
it just doesn't make sense to me and
things have to make sense I'm a
scientist no it turns out that 92% of
Fellows of the Royal Society or I a
theist freethinkers agnostics less than
10% claim to be religious so when we
talk about scientists let's talk about
scientists and cut off because they're
oh yeah they're good baseball players
and good basket I'm a tennis player I
mean not not as good as I he was so
let's talk about good scientists by some
standard and less safe fellows the Royal
Society members of the National Academy
of Science in the USA Nobel laureates
nine out of ten Nobel laureates are
atheist agnostic free thinkers 92% of
fellows the Royal Society or atheist
agnostic for you thinkers and 92% of
fella remembers the National Academy of
Sciences are the same so here we have
this problem there's this group of
people the scientists the top scientists
92% of them do not believe in a mystical
Creator now there's a problem because
Congress in the USA apparently 99% of
them claim to be religious now here's
this group of people a scientific
community who by and large of
transformed the world and they believe
something quite different from the
average from a lot of people and that's
where the conflict lies now there are
some scientists who do believe in God
that God and but they're very small
number of good scientists I mean it's
less than 10 percent so if we're talking
about statistics and I think that's the
case and there is a very small number
and I don't know very many scientists
actually I personally know very few
scientists who I mean there do know some
now that doesn't mean I don't I'm not
aware of the value of religion to
individual people in a personal level
but the conflict is a serious one in the
ethical sense because if you accept as I
do my contention that science is
fundamentally this basically pare down
level about how we determine what is
true then you see there's an ethical
issue in teaching in schools and the
netha kalisch you in politics and
everything else now for those scientists
who are religious and to say very few
good scientists whatever that means but
I cut off the right I think they have to
have some sort of intellectual
schizophrenia where they cut off here
this is where evidence base and here is
what I believe and I accept this but the
interesting thing is that by and large
at all but by and large these people
believe in the God they were brought up
in probably just had to brought up in
this religion or that religion
and there's an irrationality which
doesn't make sense and but for many
people it's not very nice to believe
that there is no god there's no
afterlife there's no mystical creator
there's no supreme booing whatever that
means after all yeah what is a supreme
being I mean you know I can't even
define it so I can't be agnostic about
the supreme being that had no idea how
to define understand the clue know
nothing you can say can that makes sense
on this issue and so I'm quite
comfortable with this obviously I think
mm-hmm who's happy about dying not many
people are and as you get older you
becomes a lot closer of course it'd be
nice to feel that I could you know still
be around looking down and seeing how
the kids were doing but I don't see any
evidence that that's the case and you
know I don't understand it really
because here's this massive business of
religion and churches and mosques all
all based on a reward you know that you
know give us may big business huge
business huge capital huge assets people
pay money and they've been promised a
reward weathers and there's no evidence
that anyone's ever got it I mean I
sometimes say you know I visited Bernie
Madoff in in you know no I didn't really
but this is anyway I went to see Bernie
and and I asked them you know what did
you do it do wrong and but he said you
know Harry I I was stupid I promised
payback in this life